.
>> Bret: SEE YOU.
♪
>> Jesse: FOX NEWS ALERT.
SAM MINI MADOFF HAS FINALLY BEEN
ARRESTED AFTER HE STOLE OVER
$3 BILLION FROM HIS CUSTOMERS'
CRYPTO ACCOUNTS.
THE CRYPTO SCAM ARTIST USED THE
MONEY TO FUND CORPORATE SEX
PARTIES, BUY DRUGS, AND HELP THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WIN THE SENATE.
IN FACT, HE WAS THE DEMOCRATS'
SECOND LARGEST DONOR THESE PAST
MIDTERMS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
BAHAMAS SAYS THE UNITED STATES
IS LIKELY TO REQUEST HIS
EXTRADITION AND THIS IS COMING
JUST AS MINI WAS PREPARING TO
TESTIFY IN FRONT OF CONGRESS
TOMORROW.
OH, WHAT A SHAME, RIGHT BEFORE
HE WAS ABOUT TO TESTIFY IN FRONT
OF MAXINE WATERS.
HE LOST HIS VOICE AND FOUND SOME
HANDCUFFS.
WE'LL HAVE MORE STORY ON THAT
LATER.
BUT, FIRST, AMERICA DIDN'T JUST
HAPPEN BY ACCIDENT.
OUR GREAT NATION IS ONLY HERE
BECAUSE OF BATTLEFIELD
VICTORIES.
LIKE THE BATTLE OF YORK TOWN
WHERE PATRIOTS DEFEATED THE
BRITISH AND HELPED CREATE THE
UNITED STATES.
OR HOW ABOUT D-DAY?
WHERE WE SAVE THE WORLD FROM
FASCISM THANKS TO THOUSANDS OF
BRAVE MEN WHO STORMED THE
BEACHES.
AND THEN THERE WAS THAT TIME IN
1980 SAVED THE WORLD IN HOCKEY.
>> THE PUCK IS LOOSE.
11 SECONDS.
THE COUNTDOWN GOING ON RIGHT
NOW.
FIVE SECONDS LEFT IN THE GAME.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN MIRACLES?
YES!
.[BUZZER]
[CHEERS]
>> Jesse: TODAY "PRIMETIME"
SCORED ANOTHER SICK I HAVE.
WE WON THE BATTLE.
TODAY THE TINY TOWN OF ENDICOTT
WILL PUT UPABLE CHRISTMAS TREE
AFTER SOME PRESSURE FROM
"PRIMETIME."
SO HOW DID WE GET HERE?
LAST WEEK WE TOLD YOU ABOUT A
SCROOGE NAMED AMBER MARONI, SHE
IS THE TOWN'S LIBRARY DIRECTOR
AND SHE BANNED CHRISTMAS TREES
BECAUSE THEY MADE PEOPLE FEEL,
QUOTE, UNCOMFORTABLE.
YOU SEE, TO SOME PEOPLE THERE IS
NOTHING MORE OFFENSIVE THAN
TWINKLING LIGHTS ON A DOUGLAS
FIR THERE WAS NO WAY THE TREE
COULD GO UP THIS YEAR.
LOOK AT LAST YEAR'S TREE.
HOW OFFENSIVE.
ONE BRAVE FOOT SOLDIER SOUNDED
THE ALARM.
>> I WAS TOLD THAT WHEN
PEOPLE -- USE THE WORD PEOPLE,
WALKED IN THAT ROOM IT MADE THEM
UNCOMFORTABLE.
THE TOWN HALL HAS A MENORAH OUT.
I SAY LET'S CELEBRATE EVERY
TRADITION RELIGION, WHATEVER IT
IS SPA SPARKS JOY FOR YOU AND
YOUR FAMILY.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS LISA DESMOND
AND SHE HAS BEEN THE LIE
BREAKING NEW FOR ENDICOTT IN
DEADMAN FOR ALMOST 30 YEARS.
SHE WAS A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED
AND SO WERE THE RESIDENTS.
THEY TOLD "PRIMETIME" THAT THE
TOWN CELEBRATES EVERYTHING.
SO WHY IS CHRISTMAS SUDDENLY
BEING CANCELED?
>> LIKE THE LIBRARY CELEBRATES
SOME THINGS, PRIDE WEEK, FOURTH
OF JULY, THANKSGIVING, KWANZAA,
JEWISH HOLIDAYS.
>> I THINK IT'S NOT FAIR THAT A
FEW TOWN EMPLOYEES WHO DIDN'T
FEEL COMFORTABLE WERE ABLE TO
EFFECT THIS CHANGE IN THIS TOWN
THAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
INCLUSIVE I FEEL THIS IS A VERY
EXCLUSIVE MANEUVER THAT THEY
HAVE MADE FOR THOSE WHO
APPRECIATE THE HOLIDAY OF
CHRISTMAS AND WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD
DECORATIONS FOR ALL HOLIDAYS FOR
PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT FAITHS, NOT
JUST FOR THIS ONE.
JESS JEFFS SO YOU CAN CELEBRATE
KWANZAA AT THE LIBRARY BUT YOU
CAN'T CELEBRATE CHRISTMAS.
DOES ANYBODY IN MASS MALICE
CELEBRATE KWANZAA?
THIS DOESN'T SIT WELL WITH
"PRIMETIME."
SO WE BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO CELEBRATE ALL HOLIDAYS AS
THEY SAY THE MORE THE MERRIER.
SO WE ANNOUNCED OUR INTENTION TO
VISIT THIS MISGUIDED
MASSACHUSETTS TOWN.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAYBE,
PERHAPS, PAY THEM A VISIT DURING
THIS PUBLIC HEARING AND ASK THEM
SPECIFICALLY WHAT'S OFFENSIVE
ABOUT A CHRISTMAS TREE?
>> JESSE, WE SHOULD GO SING
CAROLS OUTSIDE THAT HEARING.
>> THEN MY VOICE WOULD BE
OFFENSIVE.
>> AND GUESS WHAT?
WE DIDN'T EVEN HAVE TO GO
CAROLING TO CHANGE THEIR MINDS.
IT WAS THE MERE THREAT OF ME
CAROLING THAT MOVED THE NEEDLE.
TODAY THE TOWN OF DEDHAM
ANNOUNCED THAT THE CHRISTMAS
TREE IS GOING BACK UP QUOTE, TO
BE CLEAR:  THERE IS NO BAN ON
CHRISTMAS AT THE DEDHAM LIBRARY.
THE INITIAL DECISION TO NOT
DISPLAY A CHRISTMAS TREE WAS THE
RESULT OF AN ONGOING REVIEW OF
ALL OUR HOLIDAY DECORATIONS AND
DISPLAYS THAT STARTED BACK IN
THE SPRING WHAT STARTED IS
UNFORTUNATE.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED OUR STAFF
AND THE COMMUNITY AND FRANKLY
TRANSPIRED BEFORE WE HAD EVEN
STARTED OUR SEASONAL DECORATING.
AS WE FINISH DECORATING FOR THE
CHRISTMAS SEASON, CHRISTMAS
TREES WILL BE PUT UP AT BOTH
LOCATIONS IS THIS JUST TRYING TO
ACT THIS IS ALL JUST ONE BIG
MISUNDERSTANDING?
OH, YOU DIDN'T BAN CHRISTMAS
TREES?
YOU JUST DIDN'T PUTS THE
CHRISTMAS TREES UP THIS
DECEMBER?
LIKE YOU HAVE FOR THE PAST 30
YEARS BECAUSE YOU WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF A HOLIDAY DECORATION
REVIEW PERIOD?
AND THIS HOLIDAY DECORATION
REVIEW PERIOD STARTED IN THE
SPRING AND IT TOOK YOU FROM THE
SPRING UNTIL THE SECOND WEEK OF
DECEMBER TO COMPLETE THE REVIEW?
AND DETERMINE THE THAT YOU WERE
GOING TO PUT UP CHRISTMAS TREES
LIKE HAVE YOU BEEN FOR THE PAST
30 YEARS?
AND THIS CONTROVERSY HAPPENED
BEFORE YOU STARTED YOUR SEASONAL
DECORATING?
THAT'S FUNNY, BECAUSE THERE WERE
WREATHS AND NUTCRACKERS IN YOUR
LIBRARY ALREADY, BEFORE THE TREE
WENT UP.
DO YOU DECORATE WITH WREATHS AND
NUTCRACKERS ALL YEAR AROUND?
AND, AND YOU SAID YOU ARE GOING
TO FINISH YOUR DECORATING, LIKE
YOU HADN'T GOTTEN AROUND TO
PUTTING UP THE CHRISTMAS TREE
YET.
LET'S BE HONEST THAT TREE WAS
NEVER GOING UP.
NOT UNTIL OUR FRIEND, LISA
DESMOND BLEW THE WHISTLE AND
"PRIMETIME" GAVE THIS
PERSNICKETY LIBRARIAN A LITTLE
NUDGE LAST WEEK.
AND OUR FEARLESS FOOT SOLDIER
LISA HAS BEEN UNDER ATTACK.
GETTING DEATH THREATS FROM
ATHEISTS AND ONE WOMAN IN
PARTICULAR HAS BEEN REALLY
NASTY.
HER NAME IS DIANE LOUD.
AND HER COMMENTS TO LISA WERE SO
VULGAR WE CAN'T REALLY REPEAT IT
ON AIR, MOST OF IT.
HERE'S A LITTLE SAMPLE.
QUOTE:  YOU ARE A SELFISH BLEEP
BLEEP WHO DOES NOT CARE ABOUT
ANYONE BUT HERSELF FOR A TREE, A
BLEEPING BLEEP TREE?
YOU HAVE PUT PEOPLE'S LIVES IN A
LOT OF DANGER.
A LOT OF DANGER.
YOU ARE TRASH.
YOU ARE BLEEPING TRASH.
YOU READY?
THIS DIANE LOUD LADY IS A MEMBER
OF THE DEADHAM HUMAN RIGHTS
COMMISSION.
SHE WAS A MEMBER.
SHE WAS FORCED TO RESIGN AFTER
HER HATE SPEECH WENT PUBLIC
WHICH WE ARE COUNTING AS ANOTHER
"PRIMETIME" VICTORY THAT'S TWO.
CHRISTMAS HAS BEEN SAVED IN
DEDHAM, BETTER THAN A HALLMARK
MOVIE.
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WE WEREN'T FIGHTING THIS BATTLE
ALONE.
THERE WERE, OF COURSE, LISA, THE
GOOD LIBRARIAN AND RESIDENTS
LIKE MARIANNE MART